just got this email from robert
basically he goes on to say because he
listened to me after he lost his job put
out unbelievable amounts of content on
linkedin now he's got a consultancy they
can have a million a year what he was
talking about a lot of dm's i've been
getting is just like people not loving
their jobs if you don't love your job
the number one thing you could be doing
is after you get home from your job
instead of sulking or watching netflix
to escape your pissed offness you could
double down on your career and become a
content creator on tiktok youtube shorts
linkedin if it's b2b or more serious but
just start making [ __ ] content i'm
telling you all of you all of you if you
go hard for three years posting two
three four five times a day or if you
have a nine to six and you've got kids
at home and you can only do it from
eight to midnight posting once a day
especially on tick tock and youtube
shorts where you could go viral facebook
pages or something come up but tick tock
and youtube shorts and linkedin if
you're more of a consultant or real
estate just put out content just make
videos about [ __ ] you know or you're
interested in you don't have to be an
expert you can be an enthusiast